en este vídeo hablaré del comportamiento
animal si estudias el comportamiento
animal en el llamado etólogo viene de
etología que se refiere al estudio del
comportamiento animal y es importante
que sepas esto cuando estudias el
comportamiento animal hay una extensa
secuencia de comportamientos
la secuencia comienza desde
comportamientos innatos esta tortuga de
mar
nace e inmediatamente se dirigirá al mar
estos son comportamientos que suceden
desde el día 1 y continúa la secuencia
hasta el comportamiento de aprendizaje
complejo como este chimpancé puedes
observar que está pensando algo bastante
profundo bueno eso es lo que me hace
pensar
entonces trazamos nuestra secuencia
desde lo innato hasta el comportamiento
de aprendizaje la primera cosa que debes
saber es que el instinto es básicamente
cualquier cosa que tienes desde el día 1
si alguna vez pones tu dedo cerca de la
mano de un bebé el bebé lo va a agarrar
y pensarás hoy eso es muy lindo pero si
lo pones cerca de su piel lo va a
agarrar también con los dedos del pie
este es un reflejo de prensión que todos
los bebés tienen desde el día 1 eso está
programado de manera genética en ellos y
podrías pensar únicamente desde una
perspectiva evolutiva que los bebés que
no fueron capaces de aferrarse a su
madre a través de una historia evolutiva
acabaron cayéndose al piso sin llegar
muy lejos un ejemplo de esto es que en
el reino animal podemos tener a la
serpiente de hocico de cerdo la
serpiente de hocico de cerdo básicamente
cuando te acercas y la amenazas te va a
escupir e intentará intimidar te
pero no tiene veneno así que básicamente
si te acercas mucho y las molestas
demasiado va a girar su cuerpo hasta
quedar en posición ventral va a echar la
cabeza para atrás su lengua se saldrá y
empezará a despedir como un olor a carne
en descomposición bien eso es
interesante pero lo tienen desde el día
1 que en otras palabras una vez que una
serpiente de hocico de cerdo nace el
minuto en el que eclosiona el huevo la
cría tiene este comportamiento por lo
que claramente es un instinto luego
tenemos a los llamados patrones de
acción fija éstos se presentan
básicamente cuando tienes un estímulo
hay una serie de acciones que llevarás a
cabo es mucho más fácil entender si te
doy un ejemplo este es un ganso común
básicamente se sienta en sus huevos y
los incuba pero si en una ocasión sacas
uno de los huevos y lo pones al lado del
nido usará su pico y lo regresará al
nido
para que pueda apoyarlo y podrías pensar
que ese es un ganso muy inteligente sin
embargo si tomas algo parecido a una
bola de billar con lo que juegas pool y
la pones al lado de su nido loja lara o
un poco lo jalar a el interior y lo
empujará
y podrías pensar que ese ganso no es muy
listo pero si piensas en ello a lo largo
de su historia nunca necesitaron
desarrollar una mejor manera de
discriminar entre huevos así que eso
funciona bien y quizá no había en días
pasados un científico reemplazando todos
sus huevos con focos así que no
necesitaron desarrollar ningún tipo de
método y podrías pensar nosotros no
hacemos eso los humanos no tienen
patrones de acción fija pero si los
tienes si alguien alguna vez te observa
y los reconoces pero no lo estabas
buscando a sentir a la cabeza y dirás
algo así como cómo te va cuando haces
eso lo que haces es levantar la cabeza
tus cejas tiran hacia arriba y harás
algo llamado flash de la ceja y ni
siquiera sabes que lo estás haciendo
pero una vez que ves a alguien
haciéndote lo entonces lo tienes que
hacer de regreso intenta hacerlo hago
esto con los estudiantes todo el tiempo
es muy gracioso
y luego tenemos un comportamiento
llamado impronta no es un comportamiento
aprendido pero es algo que ha sucedido
durante lo que es llamado el período
crítico en tu vida los gansos se
implantan en su madre y la seguirán
hasta que hayan crecido este hombre
konrad lorenz apoyaba la idea de que si
podía quitar a la madre y tomar su lugar
durante este periodo de tiempo crítico
después ellos lo seguirán no importando
donde camine simplemente lo seguirán
pensando que él es la madre los salmones
hacen lo mismo son importados en el olor
químico en el arroyo o en los arroyos en
los que están de manera que si van al
océano y vuelven otra vez puedan
encontrarlo pero tiene que ocurrir
durante este periodo de tiempo crítico
ahora mientras avanzamos en la secuencia
de comportamientos continuamos con lo
que conocemos como aprendizaje
asociativo quizá estés familiarizado con
pablo o el perro de pavlov lo que sucede
básicamente es que empiezas a asociar
dos estímulos o un estímulo con un
efecto por ejemplo el trabajo con perros
donde hacía sonar una campana y les daba
un poco de carne molida y luego media
aquí puedes ver como media la saliva del
perro y básicamente tocaba la campana y
les daba carne molida tocaba la campana
otra vez y les daba carne molida y
entonces empezaron a asociar el tocar la
campana con comer y entonces en poco
tiempo solo tocaba la campana y los
perros empezaban a salivar aquí abajo
tenemos al oso saliendo en la primavera
y básicamente lo que hará es atacar a
todos los comederos de pájaros y
entonces asocia esa comida con esa
ubicación
y que años después volverá a ese mismo
lugar si no quieres que hagan eso tienes
que quitar el estímulo tienes que quitar
los comederos de pájaros
y luego tenemos lo que se conoce como
aprendizaje por ensayo y error la
persona que se asocia más con esto es bf
skin en el desarrollo algo llamado caja
de esquina esta imagen muestra una
representación de esta pones a una rata
aquí quizá algunas luces y una pequeña
palanca básicamente podrías enseñarle
digamos que cuando la luz verde se
enciende
si ocurriera que la rata toca la palanca
entonces sale comida le puedes enseñar
un comportamiento muy complejo
utilizando el ensayo y error es como
entrenamos a los perros la misma forma y
una de mis historias favoritas de este
tema
creo que su nombre es george klein
desarrollo lo que es conocido como la
máquina expendedora para cuervos si
buscas máquina expendedora para cuervos
en youtube lo encontrarás lo que hizo
fue utilizar el aprendizaje de ensayo y
error para básicamente construir una
máquina expendedora con loco monedas de
un cuarto de dólar alrededor y luego
enseñó a los cuervos que se ponían las
monedas dentro de una ranura entonces
salía comida básicamente los entrenó a
través de una serie de pasos y luego los
dejó ir y los cuervos volaron alrededor
del pueblo encontraron monedas las
trajeron consigo y entonces él obtuvo el
dinero y ellos consiguieron comida
llamamos a esto condicionamiento
operante cuando les enseñas a hacer eso
a través de ensayo y error
ahora continuaremos con la habituación
la habituación es cuando obtienes el
mismo estímulo una y otra vez y
eventualmente aprendes a ignorarlo
este es un perrito de la pradera y
cuando un halcón se acerca o una víbora
básicamente gritaran de cierta manera y
entonces todos los demás perritos de la
pradera seguirán bajo la tierra y
entonces lo que sucede con los humanos
es que si pasas cerca de perritos de la
pradera harán lo mismo pero si no los
dañas y sigues pasando cerca de ellos
con el tiempo se habituarán a eso y lo
ignoraran y no harán esos llamados de
manera similar si tienes una anémona de
mar aquí y pones camarón por ejemplo en
un tentáculo de anémona marina se lo
comerá si pones camarón otra vez se lo
comerá pero si pones un pedazo de
plástico ahí se lo comerá si pones
plástico nuevamente se lo comerá si
sigues poniendo plástico ahí simplemente
lo ignorará
no está consiguiendo ese alimento y con
el tiempo se habituará a la presencia de
ese plástico y puedes ver de manera
evolutiva por qué es importante no
quieres tener siempre la misma respuesta
al mismo estímulo ahora continuaremos
con lo que conocemos como aprendizaje
por observación aprendizaje por
observación es observar a otro organismo
y puedes ver cómo vamos encaminados en
esta secuencia hacia el comportamiento
aprendido el aprendizaje por observación
es simplemente ver otro organismo e
imitar eso uno de mis organismos
favoritos es el pulpo y básicamente
cuando colocas pulpos en un acuario y
les das un problema en este caso hay una
botella con una tapa arriba tiene que
abrir esa tapa y llegar a la comida
dentro de ella la mitad de los pulpos
será capaz de hacerlo pero la otra mitad
no podrá resolverlo
si pones a un pulpo en un tanque
adyacente observará a este y aprender a
hacerlo aquí tenemos a un investigador
sacando la lengua y luego un pequeño
mono macaco sacando su lengua también y
entonces un área muy interesante de la
investigación tiene que ver con lo que
llamamos neuronas espejo neuronas espejo
suena muy parecido a neurona motora
pero una neurona motora me permite hacer
algo como tocarme en la cabeza
pero una neurona espejo es diferente si
me observas tomando mi dedo y tocando me
la cabeza mientras hago eso un cierto
porcentaje en ti de las neuronas que me
permiten tocar mi cabeza un cierto
número de esas neuronas recuerdo que son
aproximadamente el 10 por ciento también
están activando sé en ti y entonces al
observar me estás aprendiendo a hacerlo
estás entrenando esas neuronas
encontramos esto en los mamíferos y creo
que es un área de investigación bastante
interesante lo último que quiero
compartir contigo es la intuición no
solemos encontrarnos con la intuición
antes en esta secuencia pero déjame
darte un ejemplo déjame darte un
problema este llamado el problema de la
vela
básicamente piénsalo de esta manera te
dan cerillos o una caja con tachuelas y
una vela y te pido que claves la vela en
la pared y luego la prendas y luego la
prendes si ya te di estos objetos y te
pongo en un cuarto después de un rato
probarás un número de alternativas
podrías intentar calentar las orillas de
una vela y pegarla en la pared créeme no
funcionará
podrías clavar algunas tachuelas y
balancear la ahí y tampoco funcionará
puedes calentar las tachuelas y aún nada
y básicamente luego empezarás a utilizar
la intuición con algo como esto
espero de veras sacar las tachuelas y
usar la caja como un sujetador de la
vela así que toma un tiempo que
resuelvas esto y algunos organismos
nunca serán capaces de hacer eso porque
no tienen lo que es llamado intuición
pero los chimpancés si la tienen si
pongo a un chimpancé en un cuarto y
pongo un plátano en el techo donde el
chimpancé no pueda tocar le pongo
algunas cajas aquí y le doy a él oa ella
tiempo será capaz de resolver el
problema apilando las cajas y alcanzando
el plátano y entonces esto es intuición
y básicamente no tendemos a ver la
intuición en organismos de niveles
menores que no tienen un cerebro muy
desarrollado pero los cuervos por
ejemplo pueden resolver problemas muy
complicados los chimpancés y los
primates pueden resolver problemas los
delfines y cetáceos dentados pueden
resolver eso y entonces lo que tenemos
respecto al intelecto es que no necesita
ser inteligente
hasta que realmente empiezas a vivir
socialmente y una vez que empiezas a
vivir socialmente tienes que cuidarte a
ti mismo pero también tienes que cuidar
a todos los que están a tu alrededor y
ahí es donde se muestra la inteligencia
de alto nivel pero somos lo
suficientemente inteligentes para
sobrevivir ojalá seas un poco más
inteligente ahora espero esto te sea
útil